[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
في يوم واحد
[موسيقى]
نظام ايران يساعد ضد المحتاجين بالمحاكمه
الثوريه
ليبيا يلتئم لبحث مبادرات حل الازمه بينها
دعوه صالح والمشتي والاجتماع بمدينه ختامس
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تناقشان
اجراء مناورات النوويه في مواجهه تحديدا
اهلا بكم
واشارت في بيانها اليوم الى السماء
في محور وزوريجيا واضافه هيئه اركان
الاخرانيه انا وحداتها صاروخيه والمدفعيه
قصفت خمسه
للقوات الروسيه خلال يوم واحد بدورها
الاداره العسكريه
حاله التاهب وذلك على خلفيه تعرضها لهجمات
الروسيه جويه فجر اليوم حيث دعى رئيس
الاداره العسكريه
في الاداره العسكريه
بان الهجوم الجويه للعاصمه
ضعف ان الخطر مستمر وان قوات الدفاع الجوي
تعمل على الاهداف
في هذا سياق مشاهدينا دعى الامين العام
لحلف الناتو ويوسف سلطن بارج الى
الاستعداد لصراع طويل الامد في اوكرانيا
وقال في مقابله الصحفيه ان روسيا لا تنوي
التخلي عن اهدافها في اوكرانيا والدلائل
تشير الى ان موسكو تستعد لشني هجوم بري
جديد وسائل النطاق وشدد الامين العام
لحلفي نيته على ان شروط اتفاق تسويه
النزاع ستعتمد على الوضع في ساحه المعركه
مؤكدا ضروره مواصله تقديم المساعده
العسكريه لاوكرانيا من اجل اقناع روسيا
بالجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات والاعتراف
باوكرانيها كدوله كدوله اوروبيه مستقله
وذات السياده هذا واحتدمت حرب الطائرات
المسيره في اوكرانيه مع دخول العام الجديد
اعلن السلطات
عشرات الطائرات الروسيه الروسيه في ما
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان ضربتها
استهدفت منشات الاوكرانيه للصناعه
السيارات تستخدم لشن هجمات مضاده لروسيا
وذكرت قياده السلاح الاوكراني انها دمرت
و40 طائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من تراث
شاهد 32 وذلك بعد ما شن روسيا 31 هجوم
بالصواريخ واثنتي عشر ضربه جويه في انحاء
اوكرانيا على اثرها على علامه السلطات
الاوكرانيه وقوع اربعه قتلى 54 جريحا
كما افاد المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه
الروسيه باستهداف مرافقه عسكريه اوكرانيه
تستعمل في تطوير وتصنيع وتخزين الطائره
المسير الهجوميه مؤكدا ان القصف الروسيه
تسبب باحباط مخططات الاوكرانيه لاستهداف
الاراضي الروسيه على حقوله
الروسيه ضربه جويه باسلحه عاليه الدقه على
مرافق صناعيه اوكرانيه تستعمل في تصنيع
وتطوير الطائرات مسيره الهجوميه والتي
تستخدم ضد روسيا كما قامت قوتنا باستهداف
مرافق تخزين الطائرات المسيره وتعطيل خطتك
كيف لتنفيذ الهجمات على روسيا
في مقابل المشاهدين اعلن رئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان قوات بلاده دمرت 45 طائره
مسيره تابعه لروسيا في اليوم الاول من
العام الجديد واضاف ان القوات الروسيه
استهدفت العديد من المناطق الاوكرانيه
بطائره مسيره ذات صناعه ايرانيه
الاولى من العام الجديد انا ممتن للسلاح
الجوي للتيار
33 طائره مسيره من نوع شاهد والشكر
لقواتنا البريه التي اسقطت اثنتي عشر
طائره مسيره ايرانيه اخرى
عادل اهلا بك حذيفه اذا حذيفه السيناري
الذي بعث يتكرر بشكل شبه يومي هجمات
بالمسيرات وانقطاعه للتيار الكهربائي على
ماذا استقر الوضع حتى اللحظه
نعم تحياتي احمد في الحقيقه يعني الليله
الثالثه على التوالي تتعرض العاصمه كيف لي
هجمات
بالطائرات المسيره الانتحاريه شاهد في
الليله الماضيه بلغ عدد الطائرات المسيره
التي استهدفت الاراضي الاوكرانيه 51 طائره
تم اسقاطها جميعا او الاغلبيه العظمى منها
طبعا تم اسقاطها في سماء العاصمه كيف تم
تسجيله وصول واحد لطائره وفي الحقيقه ليست
طائره كامله ولكن تم اصابه الطائره ولكن
جزء منها سقط في منطقه دينسكي وعلى الطريق
ونتيجه هذا السقوط اصيب همم المنزل من
مكان السقوط تضررت النوافذ الزجاجيه واصيب
شاب في التاسعه عشر من عمره نقل الى
المستشفى
كان لها نصيب من هذه المسرات اسقطت سبعه
همم مسيرات في سماء همم نيكا لايف طبعا
تمت اص الهدف واحد من مشاهد الطاقه هي
محطه محطه كهربائيه وايضا محطه اخرى
حراريه هذه نتيجه الضربات بالمسيرات ولكن
ايضا تم تنفيذ 55 ضربه من راجمات الصواريخ
وانظمه اطلاق الصواريخ المتعدده في
المناطق الجنوبيه
في المناطق الجنوب جنوب شرق البلاد وفي
شرق البلاد هذه كان نتيجته ايضا اصابات
عديده في منطقه كرسون تحديدا وتم استهداف
المستشفى العمومي في خرسانه احمد طيب
حذيفه فيما يتعلق بقطاع التيار الكهربائي
الملاحظ ايضا ان المسؤوليه الاوكرانيين
دائما يعلنون عوده التيار الكهربائي الى
العمل بعد وقت وجيز من استهدافه الطاقه ما
هي الاليه التي يحتوي عليها لتحقيق ذلك هل
هي الاستعانه بمشاه بديله ام هي سرعه
الصيانه لهذه المشاهده متضرره
نعم احمد طبعا اولا يعني نحنا شهدنا
استقرار في اخر اسبوع للتيار الكهربائي
بشكل جيد جدا واصبحت القطاعات قليله جدا
في العاصمه كيف والولايات الشماليه
والولايات الغربيه مع سوء الاوضاع في
الولايات الجنوبيه والشرقيه طبعا الاهليه
بسيطه اولا هم يقومون بقطع التيار
الكهربائي وايقاف المحطات بمجرد الاعلان
عن غاره جويه بمجرد ان تنطلق الصواريخ
واعطائرات المسيره الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
يقول بايقاف هذه المحطات والاغلبيه منها
لان الصيانه همم لهذه المحطات اذا حدث ضرر
وهي تعمل يكون اصعب بكثير ويكون الضرر
اكبر بكثير من اصابتها وهي متوقفه عن
العمل هذه الاولى الثانيه طبعا انا الفرق
من المهندسين ومن العماله الاستعداد اربعه
24 ساعه يصلون بسرعه الى الموقع ويقومون
بعملها اصل يعني لذلك يعود التيار التي
الجيش الروسي اعلن اليوم ايضا انه استهدف
في كياف تقريبا مصنعا لتصنيع الطائرات
المسيره هل صدر من سطات الاوكرانيه ما
ينفي او يؤكد هذه المعلومه
نعم في الحقيقه طبعا السلطات الاوكرانيه
تكذب عمليه الاستهداف في كيف لمصانع تعمل
على تطوير المسيرات او او تصنيع المسيارات
وهي تقول ان الاستهداف يتم لمناطق مهوله
بالسكان ولكن الدعايه الروسيه تقول انها
استهدف مثل هذه المصالح هذه المسايرات
التي يقوم الجيش الاوكراني بتطويرها وليس
تصنيعها طبعا هي هو يقوم بشرائها ويقوم
بتطويرها لتقوم به مهام قتاليه وعمليات
همم استطلاع في مناطق القتال هي في الاساس
لا يتم العمل عليها داخل العاصمه كيف هذا
حسب
السلطات الاوكرانيه احمد بالنسبه للدفاعات
الجويه الاخرانيه كيف تقيم من قبل مراقبين
العسكريين هل هناك رضا عام عن اداء هذه
المنظومات وهي منظومات طبعا تعمل قبل همم
وصول منظومات الاكثر فعاليه بالتاكيد
الامريكيه
نعم في الحقيقه احمد النسبه نسبه الكفاءه
بلغت
78% هذا بحسب القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه الجنرالفي فاليري زولوجي وقال ان
هذه النسبه جيده جدا
بالمقارنه مع مساحه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
والمناطق التي يتم استهدفه وكثافه
الاستهداف الذي يتم من الاتحاد الروسي هذه
نسبه وكفاءه عاليه جدا نحن في اخر ثلاثه
ايام يعني يتم اطلاقه على على الاقل 50 او
40 طائره شاهد نحو اكيد ويتم اطلاق على
الاقل 30 صاروخ نحو العاصمه كيف ولكن يتم
تسجيله وصول واحد او مسير او مسيرتين او
حتى يعني انه هنالك كفاءه كبيره جدا همم
عكس الفتره الاولى والمرحله الاولى للحرب
احمد شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات وانت
معنا من كيف وراس العربيه حذيفه
ايه الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث افاده
الايراني بان محكمه الثوره بمدينه ساري
شمال ايران اصدرت حكما بالاعدام على مهدي
محمد فرد البالغ من العمر 18 عاما الى
جانب حكم اخر بالسجن لمده سبع سنوات ونصف
وذلك عقب التهامه بالافساد في الارض
ومحاربه الله واهانه القياده والتواطئ ضد
الامن القومي وذكر الموقع المهتم بحقوق
الانسان في ايران ان الشاب تم اعتقاله
خلال الاحتجاجاته المتواصله في منطقه شهر
وتم استجابه والحصول على اعترافات بعد
ساعات من التعذيب والضغط من السلطان
بالاعدام في هذا الشان اصدر القضاء
الايراني ضد اي دابورقي طالبه هندسه
الرياضيات بجامعه
اشهر وبي60 جلده بحسيمه افاده
الامر الايراني اعتقل ظهرا تقي اثناء
الاحتجاجات ايضا هذا واشارت تقارير وارده
من مدينه جوان رود غربيه ايران الى
استمرار الاجواء الامنيه المشدده
والانتشار الواسع للقوات محافظه الثوري في
الشوارع كما اشارت الى استمرار اعتقال
المتظاهرين وزياده عدد الجراحات الراي
القاء القوات الغاز المسجل للدموع
بالاضافه الى اطلاق الرصاص على المتظاهرين
ما ادى الى مقتل شاب يبلغ من عمري 22 عاما
ومن قمع النظام الايراني لاحتجاجات داخل
البلاد الى تهديدات النظام الخارجي حيث
حذر رئيس منظمه الامن الداخليه
يسعى للحصول على معلومات عن المعارضين
الايراني
الالمانيه ذوي الاصول الايرانيه المعارضين
ان يتوخره حاله رغبتهم بالسفر الى ايران
وما مع بدايه العام الجديد وابيض لضغوط
سياسيه داخليه وازمات اقتصاديه طاحنا تبدي
ايران استعدادها لحياء مفاوضات الاتفاق
النووي في الوقت ذاته صرح مسؤول امريكي
لموقع ايران بان السياسه ايرانيين قتلوا
اي فرصه لعوده سريعه الاتفاق نوبي
بعقبه وتلاشيف راسي تحقيق اختراق يسلم
العام 2022 الايراني ودائعه للعام الجديد
في طهران
احتجاجات داخليه عقوبات اوروبيه اساسها ضد
المحتجين
التي شكلت ريهانا كبيرا على الخروج من عنق
زجاجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
حمل في هذا السياق مسؤوليه المفاوضات
النوويه للسلطات الايرانيه وفق موقع اجاده
ايران مشيرا الى ان طهران قتلت حدود
العوده السريعه الى الاتفاق النووي بسبب
رفضها المتكرر للمقترحات المعروضه عليها
خلال العامين الماضيين لكن بالنسبه الى
المسؤولين الايرانيين فلديهم رؤيه سياسيه
مختلفه عبر عنها في اكثر من مناسبه وزير
الخارجيه حسين عبد الله يعني الفرصه سامحه
لاتخاذ الخطوات النهائيه لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي لكنها لن تبقى كذلك للابد
لكن خلف تعثر بيين عده حقائق فرضتها عوامل
بعضها قديم واساسي وبعضها الاخر مستجد في
العوامل القديمه اصرار ايران على غلق ملف
التحقيق باثار اليورانيوم في عده مواقع
نوويه يقابله اصرار من الوكاله الدوليه
بمواصله التحقيق وانتظار اجوبه واضحه من
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه في العناصر
الجديده انزلاق ايران او تورطها في تسليح
روسيا بالمسيرات في حربها على اوكرانيا
ايضا برز موقف امريكي جديد نقل الاولويه
من مفاوضات الى احتجاجات ايران واشنط
ستركز جهودها على امدادات الاسلحه
الايرانيه الى روسيا وعلى دعم المتظاهرين
بدلا من التركيز على المحادثات النوويه
المعطله التي لا نعرف فائدتها
حاله عدم يقين سياسي تترافق مع تاز من
اقتصادي ضاغط وتدفع الاحتجاجات والاضرابات
الى التحول الى مشهد دائم في المدن
الايرانيه طالب تبدا بشعارات الحريه
والانتفاضه على النظام وتمر بالتضخم
والوظائف والاجور كالملف النووي تبقى
معلقه بلا اجابات او معالجات مستدامه
ذكرته الاعلام الايراني ان تغيير رئيس
البنك المركزي الايراني لا يعد كافيا لحي
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تعاني منها ايران
وذلك عقبه تضخم الذي يرافقه قيمه الريال
الايراني منذ اكثر من شهرين
تسلك العمله الايرانيه مسار الانحراريا
سبق لليرتين السوريه واللبنانيه عند
خالتها في نفقه
ورغم اقاله رئيس البنك المركزي الايراني
صالح عيادي وتعيين محمد رضا فرزين بدلا
منه لا يبدو كبح تدهور العمله الايرانيه
في متناول السلطات الايرانيه
في وقت فقد فيه التومان الايراني نحو ربع
قيمته في شهرين فقط ما جعل هذا التغيير لا
يعد حلا كافيا وفقا لخبراء اقتصاديين
صحيفه ارمان نيللي الاصلاحيه الايرانيه
ذكرت انه من الخطا انتظار معجزه يقودها
رئيس البنك المركزي الجديد بالاضافه الى
انه لا جدوى من هذه التغييرات ما دامت
السياسه العامه للنظام الايراني غير قابله
لتعديل مسارها والعلاقات بين ايران ودول
العالم شبه منقطعه جراء العزله الدوليه
والعقوبات المفروضه على طهران بسبب قمعها
الاحتجاجات
يضاف اليها التورط الايراني في تسليح
روسيا بالطائرات المسيره التي تستهدف
منشات المدنيه الاوكرانيه بينها البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه ما تسبب ايضا لايران
بخساره الموقف الاوروبي الوسطي وجنوحه
اكثر نحو الموقف الامريكي وبالتالي عقوبات
اوروبيه بعد الامريكيه التضخم ايضا مشكله
كبيره في ايران على ضوء الارقام القياسيه
التي يسجلها
تضخم يترافق مع انخفاض في قيمه التمان من
نحو
330,000 الى
430,000, مقابل الدولار الامريكي
مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
جدا
الله اللبناني حسن نصر الله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد
الغاء خطاب نصر الله الذي كان من المقرر
ان يلقيه الجمعه الماضيه بسبب اصابته
بالانفلونزا لكن صحيفه جيرلز سليم
اكدت ان حسن نصر الله نقل الى وحده
العنايه المركزه باحد المستشفيات بيروت
بعد اصابته بجلطه الدماغيه
عاده مطار دمشق الدولي الخدمه بعد ان خرج
عنها بشكل مؤقت اثر الهجمات الاسرائيليه
عليه
وكانت الطائرات الاسرائيليه قد استهدفت
مواقع حزب الله اللبناني والحرس الثوري
الايراني حيث توجد مستودعات للسلاح
والذخيره وفق المصري السوري لحقوق الانسان
هذه الضربه مشاهدينا ادت الى مقتل اربعه
اشخاص
[موسيقى]
ومن قسم مشاهدين يضم الينا مراسل العربيه
يزيد حلبي اهلا بك زياد زياد هل بمعلومات
متوفره من الجانب الاسرائيلي حول استهداف
مطار دمشق في هذه الغارات
طبعا عزرائيل الرسميه تلتزم جانب الصمت
هذا متوقع كما هو معروف التقديرات بان
الغارات التي سنه طالت ما يمكن ان نسميه
مسار التهريب
بالمفهوم الاسرائيلي الجوي الايراني
للاسلحه وخاصه لمركبات الاسلحه همم دقيقه
همم الضربات التي طالت مطار دمشق ومحيط
المطار جاءت بعده وصول طائره شحن ايرانيه
بعد يوم من اصول طائره شحن ايرانيه الى
مطار دمشق الدولي ما قد يدلل على طبيعه
همم الشحنه التي استهدفت
ادعاء الاسرائيليين ضرب ايضا المستودعات
الاستهداف طال منطقه المطار اخرج لعده
ساعات عن الخدمه وصولا الى منطقه السيده
زينب وهذا هو مسار الاسلحه عمليه التي
تخزن في تلك المستودع حتى وحيث ايضا
التموضع الايراني وحزب الله في منطقه
السيده همم زينب هذا هذه الاستهدافات
متكرره للمطارات في سوريا وتاتي في توقيت
اللافت مرتين المره الاولى عاشيه احياء
ذكرى الثالثه الاغتيال قاسم سليماني الذي
تصادف غدا وهذه اول ضربه جويه اسرائيليه
تنفذها الحكومه الجديده همم الحكومه
اليمنيه الجديده ووزير الدفاع الجديد هو
بصوره العامه يبدو انه مواجهه النفوذ
الايراني هو التحدي الابرز الذي يواجه هذه
الحكومه الجديده زياد لكن هل هناك همم
توافق بين مكوناتها على همم اتباع هذه
الاستراتيجيه فعلا لتقويه النفوذ الايراني
في المنطقه
لا هذه النقطه اجماع لا علاقه لها بمركبات
الحكومه حقيقه هناك اجماع لدى الاحزاب
الاسرائيليه بغض النظر عن شكل وطبيعه
الحكومه على ضروره منع ما تسميه اسرائيل
التموضع الايراني العسكري في سوريا وعدم
تخطي الخطوط الحمراء من بينها نشر اسلحه
استراتيجيه او اسلحه دقيقه صواريخ دقيقه
همم بالمئات في الاراضي السوريه او ايصال
هذه الشحنات الاستراتيجيه التي تخل
بالتوازن كما تراها اسرائيل الى حزب الله
في لبنان
واربما استهداف المطارات ايضا وهذا المطار
من بينها مطار دمشق الدولي جاء ايضا لخشيه
اسرائيل القائمه والتي روشت لها في الاشهر
الاخيره وهي خشيه اسرائيل ان تنتقل عمليات
التهريب الجوي الايرانيه لمركبات الاسلحه
الدقيقه والمصيرات وصواريخ الدقيقه وما
الى ذلك عبر همم طائرات التابعه
اا خطوط معراج التي تتهم بانها تتعاون مع
الحرس الثوري الايراني ان تنقل الى بيروت
مباشره هذه خشيه حقيقيه في اسرائيل تريد
اسرائيل لربما ان ترجع هذا الامر قبل ان
يحصل لانه لم يحصل حتى الان ان تم ذلك
وتقيب الزياده على حديثنا حول مطار دمشق
سوريا عوده مطار دمشق الخدمه جزئيه وليست
كليه ويقول ايضا ان المدرج المخصص للشحن
ونقل قادها من الشاذلي مطار دمشق ما زالت
خارج الخدمه همم زياده تفضل بالبقاء ما
يسعود اليك من جديد في خبر
مشاهدينا ذكرت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان
وزاره الدفاع طالبت حكومه نتنياهو بزياده
ميزانيها بنحو عشره مليارات شيكل بما
يعادل مليارين دولار فاصله 85 وقالت مصادر
امنيه اسرائيليه ان هذه الخطوات تاتي
تحضير لعمل العسكري المحتمل ضد ايران وكان
وزير الدفاع اسرائيليه الجديد يوافق الان
تاكد امس انه سيسعى لتامر كل لسدادات
المطلوبه الى اتخذت بل اذا اتخذت الحكومه
قرارا بالخيال العسكري ضد ايران
ليفربول
عن هذه المطالبه من وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه بتخصيص ميزانيه لمهاجمه ايران
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه والجيش
الاسرائيلي تحاول استغلال الوضع الايراني
دائما لزياده الميزانيات يعني كل سنه
عندما تاتي الموازنه يطلب زياده في
الميزانيه لاقتناء همم يعني همم معدات
وتجهيزات تلزم اسرائيل ان خططت للضرب
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه لا يعني ذلك
انه الشهر المقبل سيكون هناك ضربات ولكن
هذا هذا اسلوب ضغط من الجيش الاسرائيلي
على المستوى السياسي كي يفرج عن الاموال
للجيش الاسرائيلي لزياده الميزانيات التي
لا تذهب شرطا الى هذا الموضوع
وانما الى مواضيع اخرى يحتاجها الجيش همم
في الدفع الرواتب وما الى ذلك لكن ايا كان
هناك نقص حاليا في اسرائيل في ذخائر ال-
ال- العابره للتحصينات تحديدا وطائرات
تزود وقود مشكله اسرائيل في هذا الموضوع
ليس اقتناء هذا هذا الامر لان الصفقات تمت
مع الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
وافقت على تزويد اسرائيل بهذه التجهيزات
لكن المشكله في الجداول الزمنيه هناك ضغط
اسرائيلي بالتقصير الجداول الزمنيه لانها
تاخذ سنوات احيانا حتى تصل هذه الدخان اذا
سكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا لك من القدس
لقوى الثوره والمعارضه السوريه طلبه عقد
اجتماع عاجل مع مسؤولي الحكومه التركيه
لبحث مساله التقارب مع النظام السوري
وذكرت المصادر
توضيح بعض الامور والمسجددات بعد اجتماع
مصر الاسبوع الماضي هذا هو كان وزير خارج
تركيا
لن تتحرك ضد حقوق المعارضه السوريه وانها
ترى ضروره تحقيق التوافق بين المعارضه
والنظام من اجل التوصل الى حل الازمه
تفاصيل جديده كشف عنها حول ما بحثه وزراء
دفاع تركيا وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو
الاسبوع الماضي حيث تقول مصادر سوريه ان
انقر وافقت عن انسحابي من الاراضي السوريه
بنظره السوري سؤال باتت اجابته تقترب اكثر
من اي وقت ففي مسار خريطه الاتصال بين
انقره ودمشق يبدو ان القطارات تطبيع ماض
في سكته وهي خريطه طريق ترتكز على عده
محطات
الاسبوع الماضي شهد لقاءا غير مسبوق منذ
11 عاما يجسد خطوات مهمه في التقارب
التركي السوري فبعد لقاء وزراء دفاع تركيا
وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو بمشاركه قاده
اجهزه الاستخبارات كشف وزير الخارجيه
التركي عن اجتماعا مع نظيره السوري
والروسي منتصف يناير الحالي مشيرا الى انه
قد يعقد في بلد اخر
تجارب متسارع وتفاصيل تتكشف عن اللقاء
الثلاثي الاخير فتركيه وافقت على الانسحاب
الكامل من الاراضي في الشمال السوري واكدت
على احترامها وحده وسلامه الاراضي السوريه
في الاجتماع ايضا عن قرا اكدت انها لم تعد
ترحب باللاجئين السوريين فعودتهم كانت على
راس الملفات اجتماع موسكو بحث ايضا وفق
مسؤول تركي لرويترز امن الحدود والعمل
المشترك بين انقره ودمشق لمواجهه ومكافحه
المواصفه المسؤول بالارهاب الذي تمثله قصد
وداعش وباقي التنظيمات صحيفه الوطن
السوريه المقربه من النظام اكدت نقلا عن
مسؤولين سوريين ان الاطراف اتفقت على
اعتبار حزب العمال الكردستاني ميليشيا
عميله للولايات المتحده واسرائيل وتشكل
خطرا على سوريا وتركيا
تفاهمات القت بظلالها على شمال سوريا حيث
رفض المسؤولون الاكراد المحليون مخرجات
لقاء موسكو الثلاثي وعوده النظام ممددين
بما اعتبره منح الشرعيه للنظام
منذ وصول الطالبان الى السلطه في اغسطس
2021 وهي تقوم بفرد قرارات مشحفه في حق
المراه الافغانيه التي ظهرت في عده
مناسبات احتجاجا على ما طلعها من ضمن من
قبل سلطه الحاكمه
كسنائيه الماء والنار علاقه طالبان
بالنساء افغانستان رغم ذلك تجدد بعثه
الامم المتحده مساحيها لفك القيود التي لم
تستهدف مهان النساء ومستقبل الفتيات فحسب
بل مصير الشعب الافغاني لقاء القائم
باعمال الممثل الخاص للامين العام للامم
المتحده بقياده طالبان حمل تحذيرا واضحا
من ان منع النساء من العمل وحرمان الفتيات
من التعليم
سيعيقان وصول المساعدات الى كل شرائح
المجتمع في افغانستان لكن لا يبدو ان
طالبان ستتراجع عن قراراتها وخصوصا ان
للحركه موقفا متجذرا معاديا للمراه فما
استيلاء الحركه على السلطه في اغسطس من
عام 2021 بدا التحرك المنهجا لاقصاء
المراه الافغانيه وبدات معها تظاهرات
واحتجاجات ضد عمليه الت ما فيش
شاورما رفعت المراه الافغانيه بشكل مبكر
مطالب الرفض وشعارات خبز عمل حريه
تظاهرات سارعت طالبان الى اخمادها اما
بالهراوات او خراطيم المياه
والاعتقالات واحيانا باطلاق النار ضغوط
وتظاهرات مقابل انقلاب طالبا على
الالتزامات وشروط المصالحه عوامل حاله دون
اي اعتراف دولي بها لكن الحركه لم تستجب
للضغوط واصدر اتباعا 16 قرارا ضد حقوق
النساء وككل قرار تحمل اجراءات طالبان
تداعيات عده وتبقى المعركه مع المراه
مفتوحه على مزيد من التصعيد في ظل اسرار
الحركه على قراراتها وغياب ضغوط قادره على
احراز اختراق يذكر
مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل حكومه بشار تدعو
شخصيات محسوبه على جماعه الاخوان لما
اثمته كفيتها عن ليبيا
الجيش الاخرانيه
استهدفت خمسه معسكرات روسيه في يوم واحد
ضد المحتجين بالمحاكمه الثوريه هو حكم
باعدام شاب لاهانه القياده السياسيه
برلمان وليبيا يلتئموا لبحث مبادراته حل
الازمه بينها دعوه صالح والمشر للاجتماعي
بمدينه بغداد
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تناقشان
اجراء مناورات نوويه في مواجهه تهديدات
بيونغ
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد دعوه الحكومه
الليبيه برئاسه بعض الشخصيات المحسوبه على
طبيب الاخوان
اهلها وقالت الحكومه ان هذه الشخصيات
اسهامت في تصميم الاجواء السياسيه واثاره
الابتسامات منذ بدايه ثوره السابع عشر من
فبراير عام 2011 واعت ذلك بعدما دعت بعض
قيادات التنظيم لعقد ملتقى في تركيا
لتشكيل حكومه جديده ثالثه في البلاد وطالب
حافظ قدور وزير الخارجيه في الحكومه
الليبيه برئاسه باشا طالب الدول المتدخين
سلبا في بلاده بابعاده عن حساباتهم الضيقه
وتصفيه الخصومات السياسيه والعسكريه في
سياق اخر مشاهدينا من المقرر ان يعقد
البرلمان الليبي اليوم الاثنين جلسه عامه
بمقره في مدينه بن غازي لمناقشه مبادره
المطروحه وبحث سبولي حال الازمه حيث يناقش
النواب موقف البرلمان من المبادره التي
طرحها المجلس الرئاسي الشهر الماضي والتي
تهدف الى التهي لحواري دستوري كاولويه
لانهاء المراحل الانتقاليه على ان تتضمن
لقاء ثنائيا بين رئيسين برلمان عقيل صالح
والمجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري
الاسبوع المقبل في مدينه غدامز من اجل
استئناف الحوار والمرور نحو الانتخابات
وما ابرز الملفات التي ستناقش اضافه الى
ما ذكرناه في متن الخبر
نعم احمد هي الجلسه مفصليه بالفعل كونها
سوف تناقش عدد من الامور التي ذكرتها الان
في سياق هذا الخبر توقيت او موعد انطلاقه
الجلسه من المفترض ان يكون بعد ساعه الى
ساعه ونصف من الان حتى حضور كل او جل
الاعضاء المجلس سواء الذين حضروا بالامس
عن طريق المطارات هنا بمدينه بنغازي من
غرب البلاد او من جنوب البلاد وحتى اعضاء
المجلس الذين سوف يتجهون الى القاعه في
هذا اليوم او في الساعات والدقائق القادمه
من المفترض يعني ان تكون اولويه هذه
الجلسه او تكمن اهميه هذه الجلسه احمد في
الكون سوف تحصل ثم اجاد استئناف الحوار ما
بين رئيسين مجلس النواب والدوله وما جرى
مناقشته في الزياره الرئيسيه لمجلسين في
الاسبوعين الماضيين الى تركيا والتوافق
بشان حول عدد من النقاط من المفترض ان
يطرح رئيس مجلس النواب رؤيته وما تم
مناقشته خلال هذه الاجتماعات الخارجيه هذه
الجلسه ويتم ايضا النظر والبت في يعني
عمليه قبول الدعوه رئيس المجلس الرئاسي
واعضاء المجلس الرئاسي من اجل اجتماع
رئيسي المجلسين وعدد من اعضاء المجلس في
مدينه اقدام مساء الليبيه في الحادي عشر
من هذا الشهر حتى هذه اللحظه الان لم تحدد
قبول كلى الشخصيتين او همم يعني او قبول
الشخصيين لهذه الدعوه باعتبار ان رئيس
مجلس النواب كان يعني طوال الفتره الماضيه
وطوال الاسبوع الماضي خارج البلاد لم يتم
الرد رسميا على هذه الدعوه من المفترض ان
تحسم هذه الجلسه هذا الامر اما بقبول
الدعوه او برفض هذه الدعوه بعد وضع النواب
في مستجدات الوضع
ايضا حديث عن اخر يجمع الطرفين قبل همم
حول هذه المعلومه
نعم هناك ايضا بعض التسريبات حيل هذا
الامر واه يعني هناك حديث حول لقاء في
العاصمه المصريه القاهره بالتحديد احمد
ولكن المصادر الرسميه المقربه من الرجلان
سواء خالد المشي رئيس مجلس الدوله
الاستشاري ونتحدث عن رئيس مجلس النواب لم
تؤكد او لم تنفي ايضا صحه هذه الاخبار على
الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه الان ولكن حاله
التقارب يبدو بانها تتضح شيئا فشيئا ويب
هناك نوع من التوافق ما بين الرجلين حي
الحسن عديد الامور خاصه بيننا نتحدث في
شهر اكتوبر الماضي في الثالث والعشرين في
همم المغربيه تم هناك الاعلام بشكل رسمي
عن ان نهايه شهر ديسمبر للعام الماضي سوف
يتم حسم ملف المناصب السياديه وانتهاء
العام ولم يتم حسم هذا الملف وهذا المسار
ما يسرع وتيره همم رغبه الرجلين في حسم
على الاقل بعض المسارات العالقه والمتوقفه
ولذلك هذه الدعوه او هذه الاجتماعات
الهامشيه والغير معلنه او هذا المعلنه في
اقدام اس قد تكون حقيقيه وقد تحدث في
الفتره القادمه نتيجه للضغط الشعبي
المتزايد المطالب بالانتخابات او حتى
النتيجه اللي هي الضغط الدولي والامم
المتزايد احمد وتبقى كلها رهينه الايام او
الساعات القادمه وما سوف تدخل عن هذه
الجلسه بحسم هذا الملف وهو التقارب
والعوده من جديد الى سكه الحوار مع مجلسا
ضروره
هذه الجلسه في سياق النشاط المقبله شكرا
لك من بلغتك وانت معنا مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدين اول اني الاخبار الاقتصاد مع
الزميل
الان ارقام اسواق الخليج سوق الاسهم
السعوديه في ثاني جلسه لها في العام
الجديد تسجل تراجع وخسائر بس 0.1% يوم امس
كانت مرتفعه نذكر انه في العام 2022 السوق
بشكل عام سجل التراجع بحدود السبعه بالمئه
دبي خسائر بصفر فاصل واحد بالمئه ابو ظبي
بعد الارتفاع الكويتي فيها تراجعات قويه
بواحد فاصل 4% قاعدين نفصل الحركه اذا
مشاهدينا في سوق الاسهم السعوديه هذه بعض
الشركات التي نتبعها اليوم
نفتحي على نت عن توزيعات 40 هلا لا لا عن
العام الماضي اقل من توزيعات عام 2021
كانت وزعت 50 هلاله سنوه من سنتريس توزع
75 هلال عن النصف الاول منتهي سبتمبر نفس
توزيعات النصف الثاني همم بخمسه ايضا كانت
75 هل هلاله
بشركات الاخرى حلواني يتوقع اتفاقيه
تسهيلات تسلمي لي ع مع بنك الخليج الدولي
ب 120 مليون ريال
ناظره على الاسهم
القياديه في سوق الاسهم السعوديه وانا
نبدا من قطاع المواد الاساسيه سابك مستقره
معادن ينساب سابك للبغداديات الزراعيه على
ارتفاع البنوك بشكل عام اداء ضعيف الراجحي
يسجل المكاسب ب ثلاثه اشهر بالمئه واسهم
الاتصالات والطاقه ايضا اليوم اسهم
الاتصالات تعذيب
بعد الاعلان شركه عن فوزها بعقود لذلك سهم
عم بيسجل ارتفاعات زين على ارتفاع اسهم
الطاقه ارمكم يسجل السهم تراجع بنصف نقطه
مئويه يعني ذكر هنا بدهم اليوم ما زالت
معظم الاسواق العالميه مغلقه اسواق النفط
ايضا مغلقه همم كذلك في الكويت تراجعات
قويه اكثر من واحد بالمئه زين الجيلاتي
بالمئه الاف ايضا متراجعه همم ومشاريع
الكويت القابضه والفكم اعلنت عن نتائج
عماله للعام الماضي نتائج مخيبه في تفاقم
للخسائر تفاقم الخسائر الى 54 مليون دينار
بالمقارنه مع 24 مليون دينار كانت منيت
بها في العام
2021 وحتى كان في تراجع بالارادات
التشخيليه بحدود الاربعه بالمئه لهذه
الشركه مشاريع الكويت القابضه كيبكو في
كذا خبر عنا خبر متعلق بسندات اصدرت سندات
جديده 165 مليون دينار بنفس الوقت استاد
عدد سندات قائمه كانت تستحق هذا العام
سامي يسجل واحد فاصل على البنوك ضعيفه في
جلسه اليوم كل هذه المصاريف عم بتسجل
تراجع وهي اللي عم تضغط بشكل اساسي على
مؤشر الكويت الاول في دبي بعد بدايه
ايجابيه مؤشر السوق متراجع للسفر فاصل
واحد بالمئه اعمار سهم همم مرتفع بعض
الشيء الخليج للملاحه تراجع وايضا على
خسائر في جلسه اليوم ناظره على ابو ظبي
سريعه 14% من
كسب وهمم دائما بلاي طاقه ابو ظبي للموانئ
وحتى الدار كانت فيها ارتفاعات في جلسه
اليوم العالميه القابضه والفض به تراجعات
بصفر فاصل اربعه في المئه اذا مشاهدينا
بدايه متباينه لاسواق الخليج بعد ان انهت
العام الماضي بمعظمها على ارتفاع عده سوق
الاسهم السعوديه وايضا السوق قطريه اعود
بالطبعا انا معكم للمزيد في برامج الاسواق
العربيه دعونا ننتقل الان مجددا اليك احمد
شكرا لك لا راح مشاهدينا حسب معلوماتي
قدمها الجهاز الامن الوطني
75 مليون لتر شهريا ضباط كبار في وزاره
الداخليه العراقيه
لجنه التحقيق العراقيه بما وصف بفضيحه
سرقه ضباط للرفض الخام في محافظه البصره
تكشف عن اليات وطرق عمليات التهريب وبيع
النفطرون
فيها تسعه ضباط في وزاره الداخليه
تتراوح رتبهم بين لواء رائد شاركوا شبكه
واسعه لسرقه النفط الخام في محافظه البصره
الجنوبيه جهاز الامن العراقي اطلع لجنه
التحقيق على معلومات استخباراتيه جزئيه
بشان قضيه التهريب قالت ان حلولا الليل
كان شرطا لاتمام عمليات السرقه وبشكل يومي
والدوره المنوط بالضباط يعتمد على حمايه
المهربين اثناء احداثهم ثغرات بالخطوط
الناقله ثم مدي انابيب منها الى اماكن
تحميل النفط عبر شاحنات تقوم بدورها
بتهريبه الى اقليم كردستان الشمالي ومنه
الى سوريا ودول اخرى حيث يتم بيعه يحصل
باطم بالمقابل على نحو
320.000$ حصيله ثغره انبوب واحد وتقدر
كميات المهربه يوميا من خمسه الى سبعه
صهاريج بسعه 50,000 لتر للخرق الواحد فيما
يقدر عدد الصهاريج المهربه من 40 الى 50
صهريجا بمعدل 75 مليون لتر شهريا اللافت
ان عمليات سرقه وبيع النفط لا تقتصر على
محافظه البصره بل ومنذ سنوات تتردد
معلومات في تقارير محليه عن عمليات سرقه
وتهريب للنفط ومشتقاته في معظم المحافظات
العراقيه التي يتوفر بها الذهب الاسود
حولت الاوراق الرسميه او الشخصيه حياه
العراقيين الى جحيم اذ يعاني قرابه مليون
شخص من هذه المشكله في البلاد اكثر من
نصفهم من الاطفال الامر الذي ينعكس على
الخدمات الاساسيه المقدمه لهم كالتعليم
والصحه
الخوف من الغد ومن مستقبل المجهول قد لا
يعلمون الان ان طريقهم شائك لكن الاهالي
يدركون ذلك جيدا
ما عندي مدرسه
ما عندي ما عندي مكاني ابدلهم يعني
في العراق
تتطلب شهاده الميلاد الى فحص الحمض النووي
وهو ما لا يمكن تحقيقه في بعض الاحيان
اخرون فقدوا هويتهم اثناء الفرار من معارك
الموصل عرضهم ذلك لمشاكل كبيره يحاول
بعضهم لاصدار بطاقه شخصيه
النزوح ضاعت الهويه
خمسه اشهر حسب التعذيب وطلعت براءه حسب
قاضي والمختار المنطقه الشهود طلعت براءه
وانا متزوج بزمن متزوج وعندي ووليد
والاولاد ما عنده لا هويه ولا عندي عقد
زواج شيف يثبتوا ابنه
لا نهايه
من جهه اخرى لذا تحاول منظمه الامميه
لاجئين قامت بتسويه 150,000 ورقه الرسميه
بين 2019 وحتى منتصف العام الماضي
تعاني العشرات من الاسر النازحه في
الحديده من نقص في الغذاء والمواد
الاساسيه والايوائيه التي تمكنهم من العيش
الكريم داخل المخيمات وضعن دفعهم الى
انتهان بعض الاعمال الشاقه من اجل الحصول
على ما يسد رمق اطفالهم بعد ان هجرتهم
مليشيات الحوثيين منازلهم في الحديده
باستهدافهم بالقصف والقنص وزراعه الالغام
و العبوه الناسفه كذلك في الطرقات
على علب البلاستيك هذه يعتمد في اعاده
اسرته
لجمع نحو 50 علبه من شوارع المخاء ليعود
مساءا بدولارين او اقل لسد جوع اطفاله في
مخيم النيابه عبد الله احمد كحالي عشرات
النازحين الذين هجرتهم بالشرح الحوثيين من
منازلهم في الحديده وتعز غربي اليمن
احيانا يطلع عليه 800 على قدر همم
الامكانيه عقل المعجزه
مشي حاليا بالكيلوله دقيقه
هربنا من الحسين
ااه تصعيب المعيشه ومن كل حاجه نعاني من
كل حاجه وبحسب تقرير الامم فان اكثر من
مليون شخص نزحوا من محافظه الحديده بسبب
الانتهاكات الحوثيه وارتفعت موجه النزوح
خلال نوفمبر الماضي الى اكثر من 70%
لتكتظو مخيمات النزول في المناطق المحرره
بالحديده والمخاء باكثر من 800 عائله قصص
ماساويه تعيشها الاسر النازحه داخل هذه
المخيمات بعد ان هجرتهم الميلشات الحوثيه
من منازلهم في خطوط التماسي الحرب معاناه
تختزلوا بؤس الحياه في ظل الحرب الحوثيه
قال سعيد العربيه من مخيم العليلي
الجنوبيه الحديده
قال رئيس الكوري الجنوبي ان بلاده
والولايات المتحده تخططان لتدريبات
النوويه لمواجهه التهديدات النوويه
والصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه رئيس الكوري
الجنوبي اكد ان الهدف من التدريبات هو
زياده فاعليه رفع الهجمات عن حلفاء واشنطن
التصريحات تزامرت مع تحديدات كوريا
الشماليه بتطوير ترسنتها النوويه لمواجهه
تحديدات الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
على حد تعبير بيانكا هذا ونشرت كوريا
الجنوبيه صوره لاطلاق صاروخ فضائي يعمل
بالوقود الصلب وافادت وكاله انباء كوريا
الجنوبيه
من نوعها بعد ان اجره الاولى في مارس
الماضي وتاتي هذه التجربه بعد رفع القيود
الامريكيه لتطويل الصواريخ في كوريا
الجنوبيه بما في ذلك استخدامه وقود الصلب
في المقابل المشاهدين قالت وسائل
الاعلاميه حين كوريا الشماليه قالت نائبه
رئيس لجنه العسكريه المركزيه لحزب العمال
الحاكم وسكرتيره اللجنه المركزيه للحزب
بعد الذي
ثاني اقوى مسؤولين عسكريين في بلادي بعد
الزعيم كيم جون وتعد لجنه العسكريه
المركزيه للحزب التي يراسها كم اقوى هيئه
لصنع القرار العسكريه في البلاد وتمتلك
صلاحيات تفوق وزاره الدفاع
اعلنت السلطات المكسيكيه ان 14 شخصا اقل
قتلو في هجوم المسلح على سجن بمدينه
سواريز الحدوديه بينهم 10 من افراد الامن
و اربعه نزلاء بينما اصيب ثلاثه عشر اخرون
وفرم ما لا يقل عن 24 نزيلا كما كشفت
السلطات ان التحقيقات توصلت الى ان
المهاجمين وصلوا حوالي الساعه السابعه
صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي الى السجن في عربات
المصفحه وفتحوا النار
[موسيقى]
لقي اربعه اشخاص مصر ثلاثه اخرون في حادث
تصادم بين مروحيتين فوق شاطئ في استراليا
انها اغلقت الطريقه المؤديه الى الشاطئ
الذي يعد واحد من اكثر المواقع السياحيه
الصور
[موسيقى]
في شيء اخر تسببت عاصفه قويه في هطول
امطار غزيره او تساقط ثلوج كثيفه في ما في
معظم انحاء ولايه كاليفورنيا الى ازدحام
حركه المرور واغلاق الطرق السريعه وتسبب
في فشل السد المزدوج في حد بل تسبب فشل
السد المزدوج في حدوث فيضانات هائله
بالقرب من بلتون في كاليفورنيا
حتى فرنسا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الاخرى
على اجراء اختبارات للمسافرين الصينيين
للكشف عن فيروس كورونا بعد ما قررت باريس
اجراءها في ظل التفاف
في الصين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي ختام مشاهدينا نذكر بابراج العناوين
الجيش الاوكراني يقولوا ان وحدات صاروخيه
ومدفعيه استهدفت خمس معسكرات روسيه في يوم
واحد
نظام ايران يساعد ضد المحتجين بالمحاكمات
الثوريه وحكم باعدام شاب لاهانه القياده
السياسيه
حل الازمه بينها دعوه صالح والمشري
للاجتماعي لمدينه
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
في مواجهه ترتيب يوميا
نهايته هذه مشاهدينا في امان الله